[Music]
good evening and welcome to tucker
carlson tonight remember when political
debates were the highlight of the
political year like boxing matches
everyone would watch them it doesn't
happen anymore the ratings for last
presidential debates were terrible and
there's a reason for that they're boring
everything is scripted you know what
they're going to say before they say it
but if you keep watching the lower tier
the debates lower on the fight card
sometimes you see something interesting
it happens invariably by accident but it
reveals a lot about the country and the
people who are trying to lead it that
just happened last month in virginia
during a governor's debate
terry mcauliffe was the governor of
virginia he gravely damaged the state
he's the career clinton operative who
you may remember from his many brushes
with
apparent indictment the washington post
is always telling he was about to get
indicted he never was instead he ran
virginia and he ran it into the ground
and now he wants to hurt it even more so
he wants to be reelected and at the
debate last month terry mcauliffe
announced just kind of weld up within
him and he told us that parents no
longer have a say in their own
children's education the one that they
pay for
instead terry mcauliffe informed the
state of virginia
the government is in charge of your
child period i don't think parents
should be telling schools what they
should teach but you know i get really
tired of everybody running down teachers
i love our teachers and what they have
done through covid these are real heroes
that deserve our respect
well he's a hack a liar and a demagogue
but ignore the second part of the
sentence i don't think parents have any
right telling teachers what to teach
really
so parents don't control their own kids
do you have a right to tell the
pediatrician what kind of medical
treatment your kids should get
no
this is the new rule the government
makes all key decisions about your
children that's not just true in the
state of virginia it is now orthodoxy
throughout the entire democratic party
and as of yesterday this idea
unprecedented in the history of america
has the full backing of the biden
administration in other words of the
entire federal government and if you
disagree with that if you're one of
those troglodytes who thinks you should
have some say in what your children are
taught in the schools that you pay for
you should know the biden administration
now views you as a domestic terrorist
and they are fully willing to use armed
agents of the state to compel you to
shut up
joe biden's justice department has made
that very very clear
attorney general merrick garland
remember the moderate soft-spoken one
who turns to be not moderate at all but
a wild-eyed radical crazy person he's
now the attorney general
he issued a memorandum yesterday calling
on the fbi to crack down on parents who
complain about their school board now
keep in mind at this exact moment that
garland wrote that we learned that
murders in the united states since the
advent of black lives matter have gone
up 30 percent so that's thousands more
dead people this is the attorney general
our chief law enforcement officer he did
not issue a memo about that he issued
instead a memo about people who are
committing wrong think
garland directed quote federal state
tribal territorial and local law
enforcement leaders to discuss
strategies for addressing this
disturbing trend this disturbing trend
being parents complaining
in the coming days garland wrote the
department will announce a series of
measures designed to address the rise in
criminal conduct directed towards school
personnel
criminal conduct what does that
consist of bombings assaults no
complaining
it is now criminal to disagree with your
kids school
what have we learned from this well
among other things we've learned the
byte administration no longer believes
in the most basic precepts of liberal
democracy among them your freedom of
speech should never be abridged the
government must convince you not compel
you almost always and you and not the
government is in charge of your children
merrick garland did not give birth to
your kids they're yours not his but they
don't acknowledge that anymore so
they're happy to use armed agents of the
state to enforce their ideology and they
have to because that ideology is deeply
unpopular with most americans
now why the doj issue this letter well
because they'd received a complaint from
the national school boards association
huge donors of course to the democratic
party and that complaint cited citizens
who were upset over the teachings of
quote critical race theory and of
masking of children which is medically
unnecessary
so the group wrote to the bide
administration and said that some of the
actions against school boards quote
could be the equivalent to a form of
domestic terrorism and hate crimes
oh
so school administrators are now
protected group if you disagree with
them you're committing a hate crime not
voicing an opinion which is
constitutionally protected no it's an
act of violence to disagree with them
let's get specific
according to the national school boards
association it's things like this quote
earlier this month a student in
tennessee was mocked during a board
meeting for advocating masks in schools
after testifying that his grandmother
who was an educator died because of
coven 19.
now the association went on to say that
the feds should use quote the patriot
act created after 9 11
to the regret of most thinking people
and that postal inspectors should probe
the quote cyber bullying school board
members claim they have faced
so what does this leave us really simple
mocking someone who calls for medically
unnecessary mask mandates is now
domestic terrorism and a chief concern
of the fbi
what you're not allowed to do going for
because it's a hate crime is point out
that children and teens actually aren't
dying from co-fit they're dying from a
lot of things
but not from covid
take a look at this chart we're going to
put it on the screen and it tells you
everything it tells you that a lot of
kids are dying of a lot of different
things drowning as always is at the top
of the list car crashes too but you'll
notice that more students are dying from
suicide
in some cases directly traceable to
these policies that are dying from covid
so that is a national crisis it's
completely unaddressed by the department
of justice or anyone else in our
government
all that's addressed are the ideological
crimes people disagreeing
now for a long time school boards have
tried to shut up anyone who challenges
their orthodoxy on covet or anything
else
in may in loudoun county virginia the
newly radical wagon county the school
board used mass mandates as
justification to silence a parent who
complained they were indoctrinating his
child
i'm going to read an excerpt from a
freshman honors english class in
stonebridge
she's a hoe just like her sister
every dude on the courts
it's time for lcps to get their axe in
their house in order the curtain has
been pulled back and people can now see
the deficient leadership that's been in
this county my five-year-old is being
peddled transgender books in her library
teenagers are being served pornography
under the guise of young adult
literature
do something
be a
leader because if you know what the
citizens of this county deserve better
and if you're not willing to do it
can you please cover your nose with your
mouth you're all vaccinated what the f
what the freak give me 10 seconds back
give me 10 seconds back there you know
the rules thank you
it's unbelievable so they cut his mic
you're violating kovid law no they just
didn't want to hear him
that's a parent who's paying for the
school whose five-year-old is in the
care of these lunatics
so they just cut his mic now they've
upped the ante they can throw you in
jail if you point out that what they're
doing is hurting your children
by that standard we're in trouble
a whole lot more conduct is about to
become criminal in the eyes of the
department of justice
remember all those parents from school
board meetings this summer presumably
merrick garland is going to investigate
them too
in march my child had to watch a ted
talk in english class not on anything
related to english but rather oppression
and acknowledging privilege any parent
with a pulse knows that this is wrong
why has public school become so mired in
extremist politics and a permissive
culture that seems to celebrate the
latest popular fads like gender fluidity
and we oppose your efforts
to impose critical race theory
an overtly racist doctrine that teaches
our children to judge and categorize
others based solely
on the color of their skin
their job is to teach our kids math
science biology
literature and that's it
not ideology i equally dislike all of
you you all equally done a really bad
job and maybe it's a good time to change
something maybe start right now
a lot of those you may have noticed are
immigrant parents who moved here because
of our famously good education system
only to find out that was a lie it's the
worst
now for a lot of parents the answer is
going to be really simple in coming
years pull away leave home school start
your own school parents won't put up
with this it's their children who are
being hurt by it
on the other hand you've got to ask
yourself why let the lunatics take
control of a system they didn't build
it's not theirs they don't get to wreck
it maybe people should stay and fight
and take back the schools which belong
to us they're ours they don't belong to
the teachers union with the national
association of school boards much less
merrick garland whoever that is
they belong
to us american citizens
now the backdrop to all of this is the
people you just saw are now designated
as criminals by the biden administration
by the department of justice so-called
but at the very same time criminality
actual criminality actual violence
actual murders not metaphorical violence
hate crimes but real violence people
shoot each other and die
is rising dramatically faster than it
ever has in american history
what's the bite administration doing
about this nothing
because
a lot of these people are their voters
their political allies and speaking of
political allies the by demonstration
has no problem when its political allies
terrorize sitting u.s senators in
bathrooms
we're not going to deliver we need
solutions to build that better plan need
out of the solutions that we need we
knocked on doors for you to get you
elected and just how we got you elected
we can get you out of office if you
don't support what you promised us
i'm a survivor of human trafficking and
it's because of the lack of worker
protections that we don't have in the
gay economy i need you to stand by
workers people who are like me
it is not normal to harass someone in a
ladies room period it's not acceptable
joe biden is no problem that he said
that yesterday but you should have a
huge problem with it this is the path to
chaos and violence clearly but again the
doj has no problem with that whatsoever
they have a problem with you the person
who pays taxes send your child to public
school they're telling you have no right
to be outraged when the school teaches
your children that can change their
gender at will and that white people are
evil it's not a problem at all the
problem is you complaining about it and
if you do the doj will target you like a
domestic terrorist using the patriot act
and yet if you come to this country
illegally like the woman you just saw
taking that video in the ladies room and
harass a united states senator in the
bathroom
for not voting the way you think she
should you face no consequences at all
and by the way it's not just illegal
aliens who get a pass on this stuff
we told you actual crime is being
ignored yeah it is at scale here's one
example prosecutors in chicago just
rejected charges against five men
involved in a shootout in the middle of
the morning the shootout killed one man
and sent to others to the hospital
but no big deal because prosecutors in
chicago decided these were quote mutual
combatants
huh
the gang members shooting each other is
not really our concern the guy died
last week prosecutors in chicago
announced they wouldn't pursue murder
charges because a teenager who was
stabbed to death
was they said engaging in quote mutual
combat again it's totally fine some kid
got stabbed to death not a big deal
that's nothing like disagreeing with a
school board
and on some level it's not gang members
can shoot each other they can stab
children to death but that's not the
same as challenging joe biden's
authority to doctrinate your children
that's what they fear hey sean hannity
here hey click here to subscribe to fox
news youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else